five thousand dollars what would be the
best advice to them right now to start
an investing where do they live Upstate
New York for me I think it's really
I would probably go the garage sale
around only because I know that at nft
you can invest five thousand go to zero
a stock you can go to five thousand it
could stay between 2500 and 7 500 for a
long time if you really really really
actually spent five thousand dollars
garage saleing for a full year even if
you did okay you'd probably get that
twenty five thousand dollars by the end
of the year and then that gives you a
lot more options if you want to then go
to the next place the reason I do trash
talk is because I think it's practical
because I know how real it is I really
did find those Japanese comic books for
270 and there really are worth six
thousand dollars like it's very
practical so that would be my advice